- Good morning, believe nation.
Today's message is put
out positive energy.
Over you to you, Demi Lovato.
(chicken squawking)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- I am a firm believe in what
you put out in the universe
comes back to you.
- [Ryan Seacrest] Yeah.
- You know, even if it's as
crazy as I have this dream car
that I want or maybe
it's not materialistic.
Maybe it's like I just want perfect health
and I want to fall in love
and I want this and that
and my family.
- [Ryan Seacrest] Right.
- You know, if you put it out there,
it will come back to you in return.
And I think it's just whether
it's the universe, God,
like whatever you believe in
I think that if you put
that energy out there
it definitely comes back.
It's pretty crazy,
I had a night
where I was just like frustrated
and I was like you know
I've been working hard.
It's been about six months or whatever
since Skyscraper came out
or maybe even like eight months.
And I was just like I'm so frustrated.
Like I'm not where I want to be.
I had just released
Give Your Heart a Break
and I just remember I was
like you know what God,
this is all for you.
I'm going to do it, I'm going
to work hard, blah, blah, blah.
Ten days later, I literally
got the phone call
from Simon Cowell asking
if I want to be a judge.
- Positive energy makes all
the difference in the world.
If you have ever felt a burst
of energy that came to you
after having a meeting with somebody
or delivering a public speech
or talking to a customer or reading a book
or watching a video
and you felt that high.
You felt this was great I want
to go out and do it again,
then you know what I'm talking about.
You know how valuable positive energy is
and how much of a force
it can be in your life
to go out and create amazing things.
I think to be an entrepreneur
you have to be a force for good.
You have to be, at the
core, somewhat optimistic
and then you can make great things happen
because the odds are
overwhelmingly against you.
Most businesses will
fail and won't work out.
And so you have to believe that it will
for you to keep going.
When everybody says that you're crazy.
If you have ever felt that feeling
of the boldness and the
high and the creativity
and the wanting to do something amazing
and felt how can I capture that?
How can I bottle that?
How do I make that so I can
drink that every single day?
When you find out what works for you
I think it's critical to put that as part
of your daily routine,
ideally in the morning.
We've talked about this
before on the channel,
it's supper important.
Whether it's meeting people,
if you're an extrovert and
you like to meet people
you got to get out of the
house and get out of bed,
get out of the office and go
have a coffee with somebody,
start that, make that the
first thing you do everyday.
If you need to watch videos
of famous entrepreneurs
and see people being
successful and dream of
I want to be successful too,
start your day with that as well.
Understand that that's what
help you reach the higher level,
so plan it in.
Go and have it happen to you randomly.
I think too many people just happen
to consume the right content
at the right time and it helps them,
but then you fall back off your path
and you don't remain consistent
and you go back down to
where you were before.
So if you love a certain YouTube channel
that gets you inspired and pumped up
then watch every morning a
piece of the YouTube channel.
Whether it's mine or somebody else's
or maybe it's reading the book
or it's having a conversation.
If talking to your mom gets
you fired up, amped up,
self confident, thinking
bold, then do that.
Talk to your mom every morning.
I think once you understand what it is
that gives you positive energy
and you can factor your schedule around it
you are much more likely not
just to be a happier person,
but to achieve a lot more success
and have a higher chance
of following through
and hitting your goals.
The second part of it, I would say is,
once you understand how to do it yourself
then you can recognize
and I think it's also your responsibility
to do it for others.
If you understand how important
having that external positive vibe
is for yourself to get you in
the position of being positive
and upbeat and optimistic everyday
then how can you be that
source, that light, that spark
for other people.
For your customers, for your
suppliers, for your community,
for your family, for your
team, the people around you.
Don't be the person who's
bringing everybody down
who nobody wants to hang out with.
Be the person who builds people up,
who helps them have confidence and courage
and belief in themselves.
If you have figured out
how to do it for yourself
then you can be a light for other people
and I would say it's your
responsibility to do so.
Don't just hold on the the
goodness yourself, share it.
Make other people's lives better.
It's part of why I do
these videos for you.
It helps me.
I love it.
But I love knowing that it's
helping other people as well.
I love knowing that you guys are,
some of you watching every single day.
Some of you start your day.
If you start your day, everyday,
with a video on my channel,
leave in the comments.
I want to see.
'Cause I get message from
you guys, I get snaps,
I get emails from a lot of
you saying you start your day,
everyday with one of my videos.
That makes me feel great.
Makes me feel like the
work I'm doing is important
and having an impact.
I want to share the positive the energy
and then you guys are consuming it
and you're dishing it
out to your community.
You're dishing it out into your product.
You're dishing it out to your customers
and to your family and
the people around you.
Step one is figuring out what
gives you the positive energy
and how can you make that consistent
and part of your daily routine
and two once you figure that out,
it's your responsibility to go
out and share it with others
and be a light in other
people's day as well.
So the question of the day, today is
how many of you start your
day with one of my videos?
What's your frequency?
Once a day?
Multiple times a day?
Once a week?
Once a month?
Never, except this video?
Leave it down in the comments below.
I'm really curious to find out.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Shauna Fitzpatrick.
Shauna, thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word.
It really means so much to me
and I really hope that
you are enjoying the book.
Thank you for your support.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I hope you have an amazing day.
I believe in you and hope you continue
to believe in yourself
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Entspresso keep me going
- You have to show up at
work with the right attitude
and with a positive energy.
I actually had a t-shirt made the said
positive energy is a part
of your job description.
So the idea that I want to
show up with the right energy.
I want to show up, you
know we're all here.
Even now we're all here, we're
trying to feed our families,
we're trying to have a good time,
you know this is an
important part of our lives.
Our time is all that we have.
So to me, it's hugely important
to deliver positive energy
in a way because it's viral.
So if I come with positive energy
and then someone else is going to pick up
on the positive energy
and you take it home to
your families and you know.
So for me, it's just hugely important
to approach everything and everybody
at every turn with the most
positive loving kindness
that I can generate.
- My father
was in the construction.
So I used to like help him out.
As far as building houses
and stuff like that.
But I didn't really start working
until I got out of jail
for the first time.
When I got out of jail for the first time,
I did a year in jail
for assault and battery
with intent to kill.
The only reason I did a year
was because my father was
trying to teach me a lesson
because I was such a bad kid.
So he was trying to teach me a lesson.
So instead of posting my
bail, he let me stay in jail.
I'm like, I don't know,
16, 17 at the time.
Like '97, '96, '97, yeah.
So when I got out of jail,
I started saying yo,
in order to change my life, I
got to change my life style.
I didn't want to hustle no more.
I was never no big time drug dealer.
I was a quarter spoon dude.
You know, quarter spoons
where I'm from is seven grams.
You pay 250 for it, you
flip it, you make 500.
The first jobs I started working,
I remember I got a job at this warehouse
called IAC, Industrial Acoustics Company.
I worked there and I worked at
a flower garden, a Taco Bell.
I worked at Demo in the mall.
I worked at a telemarketing
place called Paragon Solutions
and the reason I was doing all that
was I always say, you
know, you got to create
the kind of energy that
you want in your life.
If you constantly keep creating
positive energy around you
then more positive things will come.
So I would be landing all these jobs.
Like I never was wanting
to let my record stop me,
my criminal record.
And that's what eventually
allowed me to get an internship
with radio stations
because I was just working.
I was working two and
three jobs at one time.
One point I worked at Demo in the mall,
Paragon Solutions Telemarketing Agency
and interning at the radio station.
It's like a psychic telling you,
yo, you're going to be rich one day.
So you just sit around and wait to be rich
and it don't work like that.
You know when you're
constantly thinking about
doing positive things, you got to actually
go out there and work towards those goals.
I talked to you earlier
about just going out
and working at Taco Bell,
you know, working at a warehouse
just trying to create that positive energy
a production into my life.
- There's something that
you can do in your own way
tonight.
You can validate others, empower others,
increase the net happiness,
the positivity in the world.
I mean it can be as simple
as your family's going
to have dinner tonight
and you go to a restaurant
and you see someone
do something great.
Too often we just kind of sit back and say
oh that was good, that was good service,
maybe you give an extra tip.
You're at work or you see a colleague
who goes above and beyond and you say
oh that was pretty good
they did a nice thing.
What I hope and this is
something that I tell myself
all the time, don't just
sit by and observe it.
Recognize it.
When you see someone do something great,
tell them about, tell
their bosses about it,
tell their families about.
And when you do that all
sorts of neat, exciting things
are going to start
percolating into the universe.
Obviously, you're going
to make that person's day,
you're going to make their year,
you might make their career.
I've seen it happen before.
You probably, in some
way, will make their life.
Even more, they're going to start doing
that ultra positive thing more.
The people around them are going to see
the recognition they got for it
and they're going to start emulating it.
Even though that wasn't your intent.
You just wanted to
highlight something good
that's happening in the world.
People will recognize that
you are a source of positivity
and when you're a source of positivity,
people will just naturally
gravitate to you.